♪
ROBBIE: Brian, you in there?
BRIAN: Yeah!
FRANK: How you doing?
ROBBIE: Rob Wolfe.
FRANK: You talked
to Danielle on the phone?
BRIAN: I did.
Brian Nelson.
FRANK: Frank Fritz.
BRIAN: Nice to meet ya.
FRANK: Pleasure.
Danielle might have went
over some of this stuff.
BRIAN: I grew up on a farm
in a real rural area.
I like old things.
I've been around them
all my life, basically.
BRIAN: Come on in, guys.
Uh, I didn't clean.
FRANK: Okay, that's good.
We like that.
We like it dirty.
ROBBIE: We like it that way.
ROBBIE: Oh, wow.
FRANK: Well, now we're talking.
ROBBIE: Yeah, holy cow.
BRIAN: Well, I've been
hauling some stuff in here.
FRANK: He's got advertising,
he's got toys, he's got...
I mean, a little bit
of everything in here.
Just the kind of place
you want to go to.
FRANK: Gotta ask, how about
the Foremost Ice Cream?
I mean,
I'm a ice cream guy.
BRIAN: Got that in Tolna.
It's local to Tolna.
The store's no longer there,
but I bought it from a gentleman
that had connections
to the store.
FRANK: I'll tell you
what I'm trying to do;
I'm trying to make
ice cream hot.
BRIAN: [chuckles]
FRANK: What are you thinking?
BRIAN: 200.
FRANK: Let me take
a quite look at it here.
Let me grab it.
BRIAN: Watch out for my bull.
FRANK: Oh, I see that.
FRANK: I mean, it's got a crack
in the... it's got a crack in it
and stuff, but it's definitely
not a deal-breaker.
I'll do 150.
I mean, I could probably go a
little higher, but it's cracked.
BRIAN: Could you go 175?
FRANK: I could go 160.
BRIAN: 165.
FRANK: [laughs]
You got it.
Thank you.
BRIAN: More ice cream.
FRANK: I'm bringing
ice cream back.
It's gonna be huge!
FRANK: Oh-oh-oh!
[laughter]
FRANK: Ah!
ROBBIE: Wow, cool!
BRIAN: Isn't that neat?
FRANK: Rubber heels, non-slip.
ROBBIE: Listen...
You wanna know something?
I have the display
that goes to this.
BRIAN: You're kidding!
ROBBIE: It's a guy
standing there with a kit--
FRANK: You're kidding me.
ROBBIE: No, with a black cat.
FRANK: Really?
ROBBIE: It's cool as can be.
BRIAN: The price is going up.
FRANK: Oh my god,
he's gotta have it.
I could use a couple
extra inches height.
ROBBIE: Well, here you go,
right here.
Here's the big box.
BRIAN: [laughs]
FRANK: I need
the big one, yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's
the 5/8th 2-inch ones.
Yeah, that's me.
Anything to make me taller.
BRIAN: What's your offer on it?
ROBBIE: 150.
BRIAN: You were alright
on the light, so...
ROBBIE: Okay, 150.
I appreciate it.
BRIAN: I'd have them
back in a heartbeat.
ROBBIE: It's been
a good day, Brian.
BRIAN: I felt it's sincerely
going to a good home.
I know it's cared for.
We talk the same language.
ROBBIE: Brian.
Hey, seriously...
FRANK: Thanks for calling.
BRIAN: You're welcome.
FRANK: Appreciate it.
ROBBIE: Yeah.
FRANK: See ya, Brian!
BRIAN: See you guys!
FRANK: Take care now!
BRIAN: Alright!
[honks horn]